[Musik]
hyde zu sammeln heute ist der world
wegen day und daher habe ich mir
folgendes überlegt wir machen jetzt ein
veganes rezept unter ihr gerne mehr herz
auf der rezepte von mir sehen möchte
gibt es heute eine pizza und dafür mache
ich euch jetzt einen leckeren pizzateig
natürlich vegan dafür fangen wir erstmal
an und verrühren die hefe mit lauwarmem
wasser das kind ihr wahrscheinlich schon
und da gebe ich auch noch zucker dazu
das hilft einfach dass die hefe dann ein
bisschen schneller aktiviert wird sagt
man es ist so ein nährstoff für die hefe
jetzt weiß ich gerade nicht was war noch
mal zucker und was war salz probiert
immer okay das war's mit kurz verrühren
und dann zu gedenkt fünf minuten stehen
lassen dann geht es auch schon weiter
[Musik]
so anschließend mehl und salz hinzufügen
denn erst in der schüssel mit den händen
kneten und anschließend auf der
arbeitsfläche 45 minuten lang weiter
kneten und jetzt habt ihr einen sehr
sehr geschmeidigen teig der nicht mehr
an den händen klebt das rezept ist er
für zwei portionen ausgelegt daher teile
ich den jetzt schon durch zwei könnt
übrigens alle ganz genauen mengenangaben
unten in der video beschreibung
nachlesen zu einmal durch teilen dann zu
kügelchen form und dann dass sich die
separat in zwei schüsseln gehen für
ungefähr 45 bis 60 minuten so während
der pizzateig geht kümmern wir uns um
die leckere tomatensoße dies auch sehr
sehr schnell hergestellt und zwar habe
ich hier passierte tomaten frische
basilikum salz und pfeffer und das ganze
wenn ich jetzt ganz einfach miteinander
pürieren
[Musik]
so ihr lieben gleich gehts an zu belegen
unsere pizza ich habe hier so ein
bisschen gemüse klein geschnippelt ich
habe die rote zwiebeln bunte paprika und
meist mag ich immer sehr sehr gerne und
außerdem habe ich von like me like
brüllt schicken das ist komplett vegan
es ist aus soja und alle produkte von
like nied sind vegan und glutenfrei und
ich habe es natürlich vorab einmal
probiert ich hab's mit zubereitet und
ich muss sagen es hat uns sehr sehr gut
geschmeckt ich glaube auch die hat sehr
gut geschmeckt haben sie aber auch
begeistert ich muss sagen wir sind immer
vorsichtig weil veganen produkten und
testen lieber vorher bevor ich das in
einem youtube-video integrieren und leid
mit hab mich geschmacklich echt
überzeugt vor allem ist es auch vor
gewürzt und sie haben soll wirklich
super super lecker gewährt so dass ich
anschließend gar nichts mehr hinzufügen
muss ich bereite das jetzt vor indem ich
hier eine pfanne mit etwas kokosöl hitze
und dann brate ich die so circa vier
minuten lang an und dann geht es auch
schon mal unsere pizza und als nächstes
nehmen wir uns den pizzateig auf die
wählte arbeitsfläche und breiten ihn mit
den händen aus ich nehme meine pizza
blech und den pizzateig habe ich auf ca
26 cm ausgebreitet bitte keinen
teigrolle benutzen das ist nicht so
förderlich für den teig und ich mag ihr
diesen sehr sehr dünnem teig wie beim
italiener
und da gebe ich jetzt einfach die soße
die tomatensoße obendrauf verstreicht
mit einem löffel und dann kommen die
ganzen belege oben drüber
[Musik]
so fertig belegt und die sieht richtig
richtig lecker ausschaut und das gebe
ich jetzt in den backofen ganz ganz
wichtig ist die einstellungen müsse es
unbedingt vorheizen maximale temperatur
meine maximale temperatur sind 300 grad
wenn ihr nur 280 habt auch in ordnung
dann brauchst vielleicht eine minute
länger und bei mir sind die pizzen immer
nach 67 minuten fertig bis gleich so ich
lasse mir die pizza schmecken natürlich
mache ich auch für euch den
geschmackstest noch mal ich habe zum
schluss noch ein bisschen olivenöl
darüber geträufelt und für mich ist die
pizza perfekt ich vermiss tatsächlich
gar kein käse ich vermiss kein fleisch
und um den geschmack von lightswitch
schicken jetzt ein bisschen zu
beschreiben also es kommt im ersten
bisschen sehr nah ran an richtiges
fleisch und im nachgang merkt man
natürlich dass es nicht vielleicht ist
aber es fehlt einem nichts weil es
einfach so lecker gewürzt ist und teufel
mich dass ich auch nichts mehr
nachwürzen musste nicht einlegen musste
extra und rebecca macht unbedingt nach
ich schreibe euch wie gesagt alles
wichtige hier unten in die video
beschreibung hinterlasst diesem video
ein dörfchen nach oben und falls sie
mehr wir gerne rezepte sehen möchtet
vielleicht auch mal was süßes dann
schreibt mir unbedingt unten in die
kommentare
und ansonsten würde ich sagen bis zum
nächsten mal kritisch kitchen tschüss
[Musik]